this is something that I had to always
help me back I couldn't couldn't like
focus on uni I couldn't like focus on my
life my relationships come focus on
anything
hold out a job that I thought what's the
point what's the point in his life some
transgender people in the UK are taking
massive risks to change their gender
without medical supervision and I
thought yourself
I want nice land I need this this is
something I need so I'm just gonna do it
it's becoming common for trans people to
self medicate gender affirming hormones
like testosterone or estrogen which can
be easily bought online most say they're
doing it out of desperation because it
takes years to get an appointment with
NHS gender identity specialists people
are sales people are killing themselves
and this has to stop concerns are also
being raised about the medical treatment
of young people as the demand for gender
identity services has significantly
increased in recent years we don't
really know what's going on why the
increase in these referrals in the
service has gone through the roof
and we don't really know the
implications of these treatments
[Music]
Hunter was 23 when he started
self-medicating hormone treatments to
begin his female-to-male transition he'd
been told by the NHS as gender identity
specialists it would be at least a year
until he could get an appointment with
them one of my friends who was
transitioning they no longer needed
their testosterone gel so then they
basically gave it to me when I first
started doing it I was getting hot
flushes and my mood like very like it
was very temperamental but then I [ __ ]
himself
I want nice alot and I need this this is
something I need so I'm just gonna do it
my soul or my personality but the person
whoever I am inside his mouth so that's
why I need to do this too - obviously a
lion a lion my how I feel inside with my
outer body so that's why I took matters
into my own hands
desperate for some help with his
transition Hunter eventually began
paying an unregulated online clinic in
the UK to prescribe him hormones and
remotely monitor his transition
they say that would not be here today if
it wasn't for them because it got to
that point where I just fall what's the
point like there's no value to this life
that living it's not real I'm not living
a life like this this one thing is
holding back stopping me from being the
best person I can be my 100% to yourself
so I thought what's the point
what's the point in his life
Hunter's experience of transitioning is
not unique the government estimates
there are up to half a million trans
people living in the UK not all of them
will need or be seeking medical
intervention but their queues at gender
identity clinics across the country are
growing and many people are turning to
self medication while they wait in
England alone almost twelve and a half
thousand people were seen at the NHS
gender identity clinics in 2018 Sky News
research from February 2019
that in England and Northern Ireland
there were at least four and a half
thousand adults waiting to be seen at
six of the eight clinics that provided
complete information these clinics have
seen a 28 percent increase in referrals
from the previous year that amounts to
almost 1,000 additional patients the
high demand means patients face on
average a two-year wait time to be seen
in the worst case patients face a three
and a half year way to be seen at the
clinic in Northamptonshire and the only
clinic in Northern Ireland has stopped
taking patients altogether according to
trans health care expert dr. Ruth Pierce
one reason is taking so long to get seen
is that funding for transgender
healthcare services has remained
stagnant while the number of referrals
has exploded there's also a growing
number of trans people visible in the
public world and so what's happening is
this more people come out you've got
more trans people visible so other trans
people are more likely to come out and
as a consequence of that you've got
these growing waiting lists
Jaden Lowe was a young trans man who'd
been waiting for treatment for years he
took his own life shortly after his 18th
birthday he'd recently found out that he
was now at the back of the queue for the
adults gender identity service at the
inquest into his death the coroner said
the delays in his medical care were a
significant factor in his suicide
shortly before his death and with the
consent of his father Jayden had begun
buying hormones and receiving treatment
from the same online clinic as hunter
the clinic is run by doctors Helen and
Mike webberley from Abergavenny in Wales
they were fined twelve thousand pounds
in 2018 after the Wales health
Inspectorate found that they were
operating without a license they then
moved their clinic out of the UK to
Spain to continue operating the webley's
have been criticized for treating
children but they've always maintained
that their practice was legal
administered by healthcare professionals
and therefore not akin to
self-medicating they even had been going
through the NHS young people services
for many years and each at each
appointment he was promised that his
medical intervention would come soon and
eventually when he approached the age of
17 and they at his appointment they
turned him away and said he was now too
old for again sir people's services and
he had to be transferred to the waiting
list of the adult services and that's
when he came to us saying that he just
could not wait any longer
I don't know what happened in the
interview interim and I think you know
other personal circumstances intervened
but Jayden had been waiting a long time
on empty promises and with the NHS by
the time he came to us so so your
business is actually taking advantage of
this gap in the market where treatment
on the NHS is taking so long
desperate people are coming to you for
hormone treatment these people shouldn't
be having to go privately for care but
you talk about that the long waiting
list and people imagine that that it
doesn't matter if you wait four years it
doesn't matter if you're a yellow person
you wait two years but actually in that
two and four years time while people are
waiting time moves on and things are
happening to those people and we hear
Ted tell the stories of very high rates
of self-harm and suicide in in these
people and that is what's happening
while the paper world people are waiting
I got back in touch with trans health
care expert dr. Ruth Pierce to find out
about the risks of self-medicating well
the problem with self medication is that
there are associated health risks and
basically monitoring by someone with
relevant medical expertise so self
medication can be unsafe and it can lead
to harm but given the alternative harm
of doing nothing people will continue
taking risks until better publicly
funded trans healthcare resources are
available when you're trapped in the
wrong body is like it's not a real life
let everything that you want to do you
you know able to do it it's like well
whenever I wanted to pursue like any
hobbies or interests my mom would always
be like no that's for boys no so I
didn't get to experience things that I
actually would enjoy and it should
always sway me to do more feminine
things and obviously disappoint worse
that you go so long all that for your
life for each year after year year after
year no difference you try everything to
try and make you better
like pursuit like take up you know
pursue goals like going to Union fizzell
that but it doesn't work out because
this is one thing that you know you your
society is not seeing you the way that
you and shoot you should be seen
[Music]
this is Noah Adams he's a popular
youtuber who's paid thousands of pounds
for his gender transition as he couldn't
bear to wait years to be seen by NHS
services he says he gets messages every
day from young people asking if they
should self medicate their transition
with hormones bought online every day
I'll get the MS honest years of people
asking me how to get testosterone and
saying that they can't go down the
medical route because they're either too
young to go privately or because the
waiting list is so long people ask me
all the time like how do I get
testosterone and those messages that I
have to respond to it for like I have to
respond to them because obviously you
need to tell these people that they're
putting themself in a very very
dangerous position if they're doing that
so how did you fund your surgery because
you went private right yeah so initially
I was gonna go publicly but because the
waiting list was so long I decided to go
private a lot of the money came from my
youtube channel which I'm lucky to have
obviously some of it came from a
GoFundMe I made so I crowdfunded a lot
of money for my surgery I also sold
merch to get money for it and luckily I
have parents that are able to afford for
me to have donations from them as well
so what surgery have you had done I've
had Top surgery on my chest I had it in
January so it's like seven months old I
had that in London and yeah it's just
got a few scars it's fit Noah was paying
50 pounds for his monthly testosterone
shots through a private London clinic
but he's now treated on the NHS and
paying prescription prices we're hearing
about people who are going through a
mental health crisis and even self
medicating hormones partly because it's
taking around two years to get inside a
gender identity clinic like this one
here in London but when it comes to the
children's service the opposite
accusation is being made people saying
it moves too fast and that some children
are being fast-tracked through the
system to changing gender after these
accusations came to light marcus evans
quit his role as the governor of the
only children's gender identity service
in the country he fears the cuts to
local Child and Adolescent Mental Health
Services result in some children being
poorly assessed and then pushed on a
path towards transitioning what's
happening is when someone comes in they
may have a whole mixture of problems
social phobia they may be on the
autistic spectrum
they then they say they've got a sort of
gender problem and they're pushed into
masoor path towards a specialist service
which has got a two-year waiting list by
the time they arrive at the service they
may be in a terrible state feeling that
they are very fixed on one particular
problem and they're putting pressure on
the service to give them medication in
order to stop these hormonal
developments
my whole point would be the whole this
this intervention to do be slowed down
we don't really know what's going on why
the increase in these referrals to the
service it's gone through the roof and
we don't really know the implications of
these treatments I spoke to the mother
of a child being treated at the clinic
who said that far from being
fast-tracked in her experience the
diagnosis and treatment of her daughter
has been frustratingly slow Charlie's
daughter came out as trans age 10 I mean
she'd gone to nursery in a dress for the
entire time she was there and if anybody
came around with special occasion she
would always go and put her best dress
on then when she was a bit older and she
realised that it wasn't okay she really
really tried to conform but I'd never
sort of said there was a thing called
being transgender and and everyone was
saying oh well he then we'll probably be
gay and I like I said she I remember
thinking no the gay when I know when it
a dress like women but hey so I I
suppose when when she suddenly came to
the kitchen and said mommy I'm a girl
and I've known what I know I'm a girl it
was um I mean I don't know you you just
go okay because this is a kid and it
could be anything you know it could be
like I'm an astronaut or I'm a unicorn
so but there was something there was
something really different about what
how she said this impression being given
that children are walking up to the dids
clinic and they're gonna go they're
going yes he well half
Mormons like distributing sweets and
that is just so far from the truth it's
very very very difficult to get your
child seen it's very difficult to get
them approved for any kind of an
intervention and you keep having to go
back and you know no doubt when my
daughter is 16 if she still feels the
same and she wants to have hormones we
will then because that's when they're
legal we will then be going through this
whole process yes again to be certain
that she still feels as she does which
is vitally important because as parents
and as clinicians and no one wants to
make a decision for a child that heaven
forbid they might regret as more
transgender people come out the demand
for trans health services is expected to
rise if action isn't taken to reduce the
time patients are forced to wait and
receive assessment and treatment it's
possible that there will be more cases
of self-medication poor mental health
and tragedy in the near future
and will not change what I did
definitely not lived in something I need
I need this
[Music]
[Music]